stage I'm cambrey all Bernsen and I'm
joined by David's and Adam you guys are
here to show off elite dangerous
that's very excited by this now we asked
yet David in the office a couple months
ago for an episode of my show reality
check was a pleasure we tried for like
two and a half hours in this dark green
screen studio just about science in
space so we all have that launch day
they were running on 15 minutes so let's
get straight to your is this a new
trailer you're showing off it is
absolutely this is for e3 and it's
sowing show you some of our new stuff
and for those who haven't seen the game
maybe give a taste of what's in it
fantastic let's check that out right now
and then we'll come to a live demo
that's why you've got all this fantastic
what that joystick is incredible
Jesus yeah yeah all right so here we go
Wow fantastic so let's let's dive
straight into the demo next but they
were the thing that as always and it
really struck me from elite dangerous is
the scale just seems phenomenal so can
you can really go to any any star system
in the known galaxy pretty much you can
visit every dot in the night sky you can
visit four hundred billion systems but
the point is it's that I love that mean
human space is much smaller and that's
where we concentrate most of the players
but every now and again someone like me
will want to go out into the unknown and
just have an adventure to like we've
spares and that's one of the things that
excites me about the game you start with
hardly any money and a small spaceship
you have to make your way but you can do
that absolutely however you like you can
be a pirate a trader mercenary no it's
endless choices so what is the goal then
you said make your ways it's just to try
and make money or is there like a
narrative you not told us yet or what is
the aim of the game really well there
are lots of different rankings the name
of the game elite is the top rank you
can get within the pilots Federation's
okay there's a target to aim for but
also the story the narrative if you like
is your story this is a massive
multiplayer game and it would be bonkers
for to have a save the princess story or
you know it doesn't make sense if
everyone's doing it but it does make
sense to progress the each each person
sort of life story if you like so at a
certain point if you've reached a
certain level of achievement you will be
invited to join some sort of secret
organization if you like that's the
logical thread and everyone can do that
because you say all have you joined this
oh no tell me what happened how did you
do it oh I can't it's secret
fantastic so where are we going here
what's what were you flying off to right
so Adam here is flying off to Aran in
which is the nearby system we're seeing
traveling through hyperspace here
actually can we just stop we just need
that little technical thing can we just
exit to the desktop just for a second I
think these are slight a slight
production issue I will just try to get
the audio I think I think his issues
with the audio of not being loud enough
but well just like that thing they can
soar that if you go to desktop and we
can just
keep chatting about the game okay but am
soap you were talking about it you know
you can become like this elite pilot so
what type of how can you go about doing
that what's what's the Canaccord
gameplay me we saw like fight we saw
dogfighting there we saw collecting
resources what else what is there okay
well you see the dogfighting but there's
a purpose to it you sign up to either
side so imagine there's a rebellion
going on the rebels you could run guns
to the rebels pass the blockade of big
federal warships and you know getting
those guns through will help the rebels
a little bit you could sign up as a
Mercer II on the side of the rebels or
on the side of the Empire trying to
suppress the rebellion you know and the
point is this is thing creates a
crowdsourced decision the more people
that weigh in on the side of the rebels
or on the side of the oppressors that
side will eventually win so how you to
work in terms of because it's a
massively multiplayer online game right
how does it work in terms of shards so
for example you think of some like EVE
Online and every single player is on the
one on the one shard how does it work
with with fairly dangerous right so
every single player is in the same
galaxy all right so it's like it's the
same there now they're affecting the
stable market prices you know all of the
stock markets that's everybody Mayson
that's all coming together at the same
time and the but the point is that when
we can support lots of play but imagine
a space station where you had 10 pounds
in people all trying to get in and out
you just wouldn't make sense so we do
have islands shards or whatever got you
but only locally only on little bubbles
of space because when you're all within
the same galaxy and in terms of the same
kind of like political decisions of
things that change will affect everybody
but you're not all literally in the same
space right though there's actual
interpreter C handy because people will
be dead very distributed but the busy
places no you're absolutely right you
will be indifferent so oh so it's just
in the hubs yes when you're like
separate into like little bubbles for
the rest of the time when you're flying
around and they're not know where you're
on if you encounter someone the only
well of someone else is actually they
absolutely are amazing so I didn't mean
how many people like how does that work
when you've got thousand people playing
this game
what are the odds of you encountering
someone out in space then well you'd
think it would be space is huge but
people communicate to each other and say
right meet you at this place and there
you do arrive together we have a
matchmaking system that will make sure
your friends or people you've
communicated with or people you've seen
before in the game are more likely to be
in the same sort of session as you so
you should still get to meet your people
people you're with and if you're heading
out into the unknown you will meet there
will only be one which are there even
with millions of players you've seen the
size of the galaxies read about alright
so we've got the game back now so where
are we heading to I mean are we in our
stores I mean our sources from here is
that week so what we've shown here is a
system we're going to a place called
Aeryn in this is about 45 light-years
from the solar system we've started they
play off in the premium beater at the
moment some sort of space travel going
on here that's right we're seeing
hyperspace now we've got a volume of
space of about 200 cubic light-years
just arrived near the star and we're
going to we're going to go and find some
trouble
great I love trouble it's so fantastic
so wise saying earlier about the you
know why do you go engage in combat the
idea answer is you do it for money but
you can also do it for fame and
reputation okay so if you are helping
that the rebel side in the rebels win
the system might become independent but
that might mean that all the people have
been mining or suddenly get a proper
wage so the price of all goes up so the
price of metal goes up so the price of
the spaceship you're trying to save up
for goes up okay now you so you might
think alright second maybe a health I'd
pick the other side with those depresses
so you mention spaceship so and you can
learn this just like your initial
starting craft were in at the moment
this is this is sort of one up from it
this is the starting craft is something
called a side one which is general
purpose spaceship okay small cargo bay
but reasonable at everything not
brilliant at any one thing this is an
eagle which is a combat leaning craft so
it's got more what we call hard points
and guess why we're looking for trouble
like yeah that's right it's tougher it's
tougher right it's still not got very
big cargo bay
okay there are other ships in there that
are about like big trucks
they've got relatively flimsy
construction only a few hard points but
cavernous cargo bays
so you rely on shields because shields
take all the hits first and then damage
to the hull come got you so Adam is
controlling right now how does the
control scheme work well it's it sorry
okay different so we what we're seeing
here is the flight think this is our
favorite way of controlling okay we also
support mouse keyboard or keyboard only
for the hardened people from the
original games okay but it works really
well with these controllers you get the
solidity of those ships and also they've
got so many buttons it's fantastic this
is a full-on PC game we use lots of sort
of shortcuts for things yeah but you can
map them to all the buttons on these
wonderful controllers it's a game
gamepad supported like your throne say
xbox 360 pad for example RPS PlayStation
for one game plan works fine and
actually to be honest I started off
playing it like that thinking oh so used
to gaming on 360 and ps3 and ps4 but
having it's when you go this it's a bit
of a learning curve because it said I've
not used a stick for ages before this
game to be honest but once you've done
it it feels so good it feels it feels
plasticky going back somehow and of
course at the other input that air you
guys are we talking about is a fact that
this is oculus rift compatible and so
how is that working I mean have you have
you had it set up with development kit -
yeah have you tried there with the
positional camera is there going to be
positional tracking at some point like
what's the situation right we have DK -
we support it today we have the tracking
we fully support that I mean so you can
lean out and actually the the something
called a lake on type name or it's got a
big crane cab on the front I could
actually lean back and see the damage to
your ship as it happens it's really
quite eerie but the way we see it is I
mean we have got our own tools and
technology which has really enabled us
to push what we've done in this game
really hard and really well I think but
the key point with that with able to
support oculus very quickly you know a
lot of our backers and you know we're
writing this game for ourselves and then
for the including the backers as part of
the why I say is ourselves and we wanted
support for ped - I think it's great
it's so immersive we're going to say
that the game is stunningly beautiful
like I'm not I'm not seen it err this
build running before flying past a
spaceship there's amazing huh so what's
going on did you cause that damage Adam
was that you know so what I'm doing at
the moment this the capital ship has
released a distress signal so he's under
attack from
these these rebels here so I can come in
and help them out and take out the
rebels and you know help him out from
being destroyed so there's both employer
controlled and craft and also AI
controlled craft definitely dangerous
okay what are the key things you know
that is to get the balance of the game
really good in the sense of not wanting
players to suffer griefing for me some
of my best multiplayer game experiences
have been come on yes so where Claire's
cooperate against a common bad guy with
most of the ships you meet in the game
will be AI and every all of the player
ships are in the pilots Federation and
Pilots Federation cracks down really
hard on people that attack players
that's not to say you can't and won't do
it but imagine someone who's been bit of
a creeper they will have a huge bounty
on their head and the Moses layers will
muscular police will go after them and I
thought the way obviously you can become
a bounty hunter absolutely all right
Oh excellent we've seen that already in
the premium Vita you know where we've
seen vigilantism going all right extra
let's all go after him so it's a self
balancing thing thing and what about
like collection of resources stuff how
does that work we can do physically mind
stuff or is that by stealing cargo or
how to work yeah you can I mean we also
have the idea of gold rushes so someone
will there's lots of gold out there
someone will discover a goldrich belt
around a planet or a star and they were
mining they'll try and keep it secret
but other players will see people coming
back with big cargoes of gold and I
wonder where that came from and so yes
you can mine it but actually it's
probably more advantageous to try and
get someone else to mine it and maybe go
out and sell them things you know in the
gold rush in 18-49 the people who made
the most money the people selling the
spades I didn't know that so like this
this craft here um how big I hope bigger
the ships that you can pilot they could
you one day buy that ship and pilot that
right you so you can get military ships
but you have to have said your
reputation is really important if you've
got a strong alignment with one of the
superpowers
this is a federal warship again you can
get something called a federal cutter
which is a big ship very very big ship
you can only buy that if you've got a
decent franc in the Federation gosh
there's a similar Imperial ship as well
that you can also buy you can't get
ships as big as this currently in the
first release of the game you'll get
ships that you fly directly giant ships
like that would only be flown under what
we call executive control you know it'd
make these these a seat-of-the-pants
ships so the biggest ships can be docked
at a slot but only just they completely
fill in they here okay um so how about
like controlling ships with other
players is that something you've thought
about like if you could you team up with
other players and all get inside one
ship yes so we're planning via dude so
the ship the Eagle ship that Adams
flying now is a one-seater but some of
the larger ships like the Cobra is the
smallest of the larger ships if that
makes sense it's got two seats yeah
you've seen that that's already in
premium beta the plan is ultimately
another player would be able to sit in
the other sheep seat and cooperate
that'd mean because at the moment is
there any sort of when you dock in a
space station can you get out and walk
around is there is that type of gameplay
exists so we have I mean you can see in
some of the ships you look around you
see that we've actually modelled out
elements of the inside already we know
what's inside those ships we will be the
ability to walk around but after the
first commercial release of the game
we're going to bring these answer
expansions because with all these some
things I think the key point is to stay
focused make sure we get this element of
the game right we will then make that
element of a game really good because
lots of things walking around pointless
until you have things like forwarding
other ships until you can get out walk
around stations ultimately land on
planets get out walk out maybe have
vehicles you drive around the surface
you know that it's each of those stages
we've got to get it right we want it to
be great if the planet surface is just
lifeless there's no point what I want is
to be able to get out onto the planet's
surface ultimately to do things like
going big-game hunting no chasing big
dinosaurs around if you like
so when we tried last time David them I
was really impressed and surprised by
the level of detail and authenticity I
guess would be the word so you know you
were talking about um you know you want
to try and keep it as true to real life
science as you possibly can yet you know
they're obviously asked has to be fun
then you have to be able to get places
you know cuz like without interests when
you saw faster than light or too close
to light speed travel it would take you
seventy thousand years to get to the
need on the nearest store and like I
don't care how good your game is I'm not
gonna play for seventy thousand years so
what's that tack how'd you get that
how'd you get that balance right yeah
well what we've decided I mean we've got
we are a scientifically accurate as we
can we don't have artificial gravity and
things I've always spin stuff the
distances are all right there is our one
big sort of fingers-crossed element
where we suspend reality is hyperspace
travel and we figure we want to take the
maximum advantage over that so we've got
super cruise you can travel many many
tens at the speed of lights and you zoom
around the systems it feels wonderful it
gives you a feeling of scale we've also
got hyperspace travel which we don't
there isn't a real basis for that
other than the fact that the world it
wouldn't work and who knows that may
well be
astok so let's go back to the kind of
some of the combat with you seeing it
Adam flying around and did some pretty
good blasting so I mean hey well how
long do I take to take down a ship I
mean it is the all matter where you
shoot it like it is yeah does that make
a difference so if you're going up
against another ship all your damage if
it's got shields
I've nickel er taken by the shields
right irrespective of where you hit it
that's right well there are different
shield units so you could take down just
one shield in for the really large ships
all at the moment they're all one zone
once you're through that you can then
focus on individual parts of the ship
aiming at the cockpit just damage to
that aiming at individual elements of
the ship might disable it
hands to you as well you can hear it
hitting your ship around you but as you
can see individual systems so you could
take out the shields with one type of
weapon and then target the enemy's
weapons disable them and absolutely not
take that of a thing so for example
lasers are very good against Steel's
missiles are much better against the
hull so can you do something like if you
if you you know kicking someone's ass
could you disable the shields take out
the weapons and then then like speak to
them and be like give me all your money
and I'll let ya if I can do it first you
can just say look I got a big ship and
one of the good tactics actually which
you can do now is you can target the
cargo bay and get the door to open some
cargo might come out but actually more
importantly it's a quite a good thing to
do is jettison a bit of cargo someone's
beating you in battle you just start
getting stand in cargo and they'll stop
to pick it up while you're drive
spinning if they've got a difficult
decision because if they chase after you
they're going to lose that cargo anyway
you know so it's a nice balance a bit
like throwing change someone who's
trying to mug you briefly but I think we
have to finish it there guys but thank
you so much David it's been a pleasure
to have your stages thank you again
thanks so much Adam well boy well Floyd
very impressive right guys don't go
anywhere we will be right back with a
little game called organic panic in just
a minute so seen it see you then